hello there I'm down under where the
slow mo guys without our lab coat yeah
we've actually got these very
fashionable sort of CCC little bit
babylons ooh yeah
so like I should be playing like a robot
though yeah where where are we right now
we're at the metal casting Research Lab
at Purdue University
and we're going to be doing some molten
metal pouring onto this plate absolutely
that's not just any metal right you can
I've seen you know videos of mosted
aluminium thing force but that melts 600
degrees C as we're doing child's play
nothing nothing
you know about garden copper rimmel to
over 1,000 85 degrees we can be poor yet
1200 degrees C over 2,000 degrees I
think for this one resolution is going
to make this a lot nicer than speed so
we'll film it a thousand frames a second
but in 4k first we'll get a light on it
and I think after that we'll just let it
will expose to its own glow so it will
just be you know surreal molten droplets
splashing and 4k I think you are
I don't be classed it well if neither
we're agreed on the fact that will be
class let's move us to it I'll be by
induction so the coil Michael coil mm
exactly they're between 10,000 burst
signal
creating petty currency in the metal yes
and it was even kind of melting there's
no no gas is burned a very clean way to
melting so I'm gonna be initiated what's
up
basically I was pretty scared yeah
obviously 1,200 degrees hot melting
copper and I've got these pour in and
unlike their other practices and by the
time I wake on the grip right okay I'm
ready
it's a really cool it's like you're
going to be pour it in like yeah heavy
is the thing for level I saw I grabbed
it was destined for it yeah yeah lady
because it's 12 degrees per minute but
it just goes below tour was in 1085 then
it solidified so they got very few very
small that time to be able to pull it
here's forget that bat mouth but when
it's liquid it's still mouth but yeah
still heavy iron yeah
okay ready
[Music]
so good you get hit you're right awesome
yeah yeah true your man really no you're
right yep you can't really push the
bottom of these things
[Music]
now that I go went well I didn't check
it out it was a good end you went really
high and it landed straight on the other
pack quite happy that it's quite quite
distracting a lot pressure when you've
got molten copper 12 and it's at the
hand and you're like trying to aim it
all right we show off our little platter
we've got that with knife I think what
we'll do now for a bit of variation is
repeat the experiment we'll turn off the
lights though and I'm going to go wide
open on this lens so hopefully it will
just be illuminated by its red hotness
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he did well to get in folks especially
that the focus that I gave me was about
inch and you'll nail it boys
I love that this is one of the things I
can just watch this all day let's give
me a screen saver for me
silence good luck it looks like mellitus
metal rain
purfles blowing hot metal falling and
then just like it's the exact same as
water where it just turns into
individual droplets by the time it hits
you get loads of lovely splashes yeah
it's very surreal the phrase doesn't
glow right everywhere and burn people
wouldn't you got me you got me in the
hand
I was that early - I was like what i de
pasto yeah yeah keep going
thankfully we didn't crackle end and
just some skin got burn on online
actually once again the glowing hot
metal where I get burnt and you don't I
don't know how that keeps happening I
was telling exit forward but to be fair
when I was watching cuz you're watching
the camera
I'm pouring here and it's red you know
if it's a couple of meters everywhere
like liquid metal for a little bit you
probably find balls of it yeah well
hopefully you enjoyed that video please
let us know if you like these science
lab experiments because we can do more
feel free to follow us on twitter by
some merch and if anyone knows how to
power down Stan please let me know he's
out of control if we got a second
channel - he's done